möchte es wirklich schauspielerin werden
als eigentlich natürlich warum also
überlegt ob sie behalten werden würde
deshalb das muss verhindert werden
maxi nicht demnächst einmal zu einer
probe kommt ich suche noch nicht alle
irgendwas to go lasst uns trinken wie
ich sehe keine entscheidung gefallen
das ist sie arbeitslos fischer weißt du
ich musste trotzdem treffen
ich muss ihn kennenlernen er kennt mich
so gut wir haben uns so viele schöne e
mails geschrieben und er ist so ein
sensibler mensch witzig einfühlsam das
muss er sein aber trotzdem fand ich sein
verhalten sie nicht groß
es wirkt schon fast als wäre er von ihr
davon gelaufen und das geht nicht die
sachen ist ein abschluss gebracht ich
kann nicht gut verstehen und ich glaube
auch dass ben natürlich davon gerannt
ist warum man sich vor die versteckt hat
das kann ich selbst erkläre zum abitur
oder soll ich lieber wenn du zu dir
sagen du bist viel